je souhaitrais d'abord revenir sur le
cadrage financier proposé par ce projet
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale alors il s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire vous le savez plus large
celle que nous avons proposé dans le
projet loi de de programmation des
finances publiques l'objectif et de
parvenir d'ici 2027 à une réduction de
notre déficit en dessous du seuil des 3
%. il en va de la soutenabilité de notre
système et l'ensemble des
administrations dont la sécurité sociale
doit y contribuer c'est la raison pour
laquelle le PLFSS qui vous a proposé
poursuit l'investissement massif pour la
sécurité sociale dans le champ par
exemple de la santé de l'accès au
médicaments de l'autonomie ainsi le
PLFSS prévoit pour 2024 plus de 640
milliards d'euros de dépenses en hausse
et j'insiste làdus en hausse de 30
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2023
cette augmentation s'explique notamment
par le mécanisme protecteur d'indexation
des prestations sur l'in inftion qui
représente 14 milliards d'euros pour les
retraites par exemple tout en
poursuivant cet investissement pour la
sécurité social le PLFSS prévoit
d'importantes économies la construction
de longondam 2024 en est une parfaite
illustration nous prévoyons en effet une
rectification de longam 2023 de 2,8
milliards d'euros une progression de
longam 2024 de 3,2 % soit un niveau très
largement supérieur à l'inflation qui
devrait qu elle sélevé à 2,5 %. la
hausse des dépenses en 2024 concernera
en particulier le secteur hospitalier
puisque pour la 2e année consécutive
l'ONDAM hospitalier dépassera les 100
milliards d'euros sous un niveau
historique l'ONDAM médico-social
représentera quant à lui plus de 30
milliards d'euros plus précisément pour
2023 la rectification de londam
permettra de financer les
revalorisations salariales en faveur des
professionnels de nos établissements
sanitaires et médicausociaux il s'agit
d'un effort inédit la révision à la
hausse de longam permettra aussi
d'abonder le fond d'urgence pour les
éepades annoncé par la première ministre
cet été qui disposera ainsi de 100
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
établissement en difficulté pour 2024
les revalorisations salariales prendront
effet sur toute l'année et
représenteront 6,2 milliards d'euros qui
viennent s'ajouter aux 10,9 milliards
d'euros déjà prévus par le Ségure de la
santé
l'ONDAM permettra aussi de soutenir la
branche autonomie en prévoyant les
moyens nécessaires à la création des
6000 ETP supplémentairire en éepad il
s'agira aussi de financer la mise en
place progressive des 50000 solutions
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap dont le coût sera de 1,5
milliards d'euros d'ici 2030